[Music]
on this sunday night the rapid rise of
omicron
the new variant helps set new records
i'm absolutely terrified by what's
expected to happen the growing concern
over what's in store this winter omicron
in america it is just you know raging
through through the world the variant
reaches nearly all 50 u.s states but
americans are still hesitant to get the
vaccine pro sports on pause the leagues
hit hard by covid and the calls to
postpone play indefinitely and the
shifting pattern of tornado alley where
severe weather will strike next
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us go the 19 cases and restrictions are
on the rise across the country ahead of
the holiday season quebec recorded more
than 3 800 new cases today that's the
most in that province since the pandemic
began for the fourth day in a row nova
scotia has set a new single day record
with nearly 500 new confirmed cases and
ontario is reporting its highest case
count since april with more than 4 100
new infections the driving force behind
the surge omicron and as david aiken
reports experts say more records will be
broken and more needs to be done to
prepare
the math of omicron is simple and
inevitable omicron's r value its
reproductive rate is anywhere between
three and five in canada a single case
two or three days later turns into three
cases two or three days later turns into
nine cases two or three days later turns
into 27 cases now only a small
percentage of the omicron infected will
need hospital care but with the sheer
number of expected cases even a small
percentage could overwhelm health care
systems if we even see you know 0.01
of all the cases and we expect you know
a third of the population to get it
that's enough to cause a lot of
difficulties in the health care system
rising case counts have also brought
renewed concern for those living in and
working in long-term care facilities as
a physician who works on the front line
of long-term care i'm absolutely
terrified by what's expected to happen
with the omicron variant one reason for
that concern booster rates still too low
we just learned that 32 percent only 32
percent of the front-line staff and
long-term care have their booster and
only 86 percent of the residents so this
is a clear problem we need to really
treat this as an emergency at this point
in time in ontario the number of
long-term care homes where a public
health official has declared an outbreak
has doubled in just the last two weeks
and those living in retirement homes may
also be increasingly vulnerable where
vaccination rates among staff are even
lower than in long-term care
unfortunately retirement housing is you
know the wild west of congregate care
there's you know far less oversight than
you have in long-term care experts say
authorities also need to start promoting
the use of n95 masks as growing research
shows cloth or surgical masks do little
to stop omicron spread anyone who's
entering a long-term care facility
should be provided with an n95 mask this
is unprecedented in terms of our case
numbers and really again just very
uncontrolled epidemic growth doctors and
other experts say governments need a
pivot in their public health strategy to
deal with that rapid growth david aiken
global news ottawa
despite this new wave the nhl season
will go on but cross-border games are
postponed for christmas in the nba the
raptors are still allowing spectators
but only filling the arena at half
capacity there's an international
sporting event about to take place in
canada the world junior hockey
tournament and as ross lord explains
there are calls to put that on pause
at a game that would normally be sold
out the crowd was at half capacity by
government order as the toronto raptors
hosted the golden state warriors
saturday night both teams have players
in covid protocols including raptor's
star pascal ciacom the league best
warriors didn't even bring their whole
team to canada fearing stars could end
up stuck in quarantine as the nba and
other pro sports leagues hang on to
their seasons by a thread it's a
minefield
and
it has to be i'm sure the nba is
thinking about all of these
uh potential
areas of controversy these health
concerns very carefully the national
hockey league has already postponed
dozens of games five teams now shut down
through hockey's christmas holiday break
the vancouver canucks weekend games were
scrapped just hours before fans were to
show up at the arena the last minute
cancellation that upended some family's
weekend plans
it was all excited for his first game
here and uh we're from toronto but we
hate the leafs so we came to vancouver
this was his christmas gift and
unfortunately due to coven not much you
can do as stars like the maple leafs
captain john tavares are sidelined there
are calls for the nhl to match the
national football league the nfl has
decided to end mandatory testing for
players if they're vaccinated and have
no signs of illness i think you might
take it a step further and question
why are we even testing
for guys that have no symptoms
some infectious disease specialists say
there's still not enough evidence about
omicron's severity to start backing off
there are growing doubts about going
ahead with the upcoming world junior
hockey championship in edmonton and red
deer alberta and whether february's
beijing olympics will go ahead the nba
seems determined to see its season
through with its lucrative christmas day
matchups approaching if it's feasible
and it doesn't look
too awful from a public relations
standpoint i think that's what they're
going to try to do navigating the
schedule is increasingly complicated
monday's game between the raptors and
visiting orlando is now off too there
are too many players and staff on the
magic and covert protocol for them to
play
ross lord global news
in the u.s tonight nearly all 50 states
are reporting covet 19 cases involving
the new variant doctors are urging
everyone to get vaccinated but tens of
millions of eligible americans are still
not immunized as jennifer johnson
reports the american president is
preparing to address the nation with a
new plan to fight this new wave
new cases of coba 19 in the u.s are now
topping 120 thousand a day a twenty
percent increase over the past two weeks
doctors are predicting a winter of
severe illness and possible death for
the unvaccinated with the delta variant
still spreading in cases of omicron now
in nearly all 50 states if we're going
to deal with omicron successfully
vaccinated people need to get boosted
and obviously people who are not
vaccinated clearly need to get
vaccinated now more than ever but the
push to get people vaccinated has fallen
on deaf ears for a third of the country
booster shots too just under 30 percent
of americans have gotten them so far
with millions traveling for the
christmas holiday anxiety is surging too
i'm very concerned about it because
the flights are full
inside the lobby is full protectors
don't inject us vaccine hesitancy and
opposition remain high even with more
high profile deaths washington state
senator doug erickson was an outspoken
critic of vaccine mandates he's now died
after a month-long battle with
copenhagen
u.s president joe biden will address a
nation on edge tuesday on how the
country will fight this latest threat at
federal help for communities overwhelmed
with the sick and dying many hospitals
are already stretched thin including
some in ohio where the governor has sent
in the national guard to help
my biggest fear is just you know the
health care system at large being able
to care for all the things that we've
been asked to do harvard university has
joined a growing list of schools and
companies going remote for the next
several weeks cnn has told most of its
staff to work from home
many new york city restaurants and
broadway shows have shut their doors as
city officials dramatically expand the
number of testing sites omicron really
has thrown a curveball here i think that
this is a temporary
incident i think omicron is going to
blow its way through the population
probably very quickly but we do face a
hard four to six weeks ahead of us
complicating the situation the two drugs
most effective in treating kobit 19 for
those who end up in the hospital are not
nearly as effective fighting the omicron
strain it's a brand new version and it
is so different that it has the
properties to potentially be evasive
pharmaceutical companies are working on
new treatments but say that will take
several months for now health care
experts say vaccines and boosters are
our best weapons
jennifer johnson global news washington
in the u.k london's wembley stadium has
been turned into a massive vaccination
center in an effort to give out as many
booster shots as possible before the new
year long lines formed outside the
country's largest stadium britain has
stepped up its vaccination campaign in
an attempt to counter the rapid rise in
infections more than 82 000 new cases
were confirmed across the uk today
britain's health secretary isn't ruling
out further restrictions before
christmas
we are assessing the situation it's very
fast moving we've seen with omu kron
there is a there's a lot that we still
don't know about home economy that's the
truth of the matter uh the the reality
is there's a lot of uncertainty there
are gaps in the data
around 60 percent of new coven 19 cases
in england are omicron
israel's prime minister says omicron has
sparked a fifth wave of the pandemic
across that country the surge in cases
has prompted israel to look at adding
several countries including canada and
the u.s to its no-fly list if approved
travel to and from those countries would
be banned citizens would only be allowed
to travel to one of the listed countries
if they have special permission there
are already 52 countries on israel's red
list
in hong kong ballots are being counted
in the first election since beijing
changed laws to ensure only candidates
loyal to china can run more than 4
million people are eligible to vote but
only about a third cast a ballot that's
the lowest voter turnout since 1991.
foreign governments and democracy groups
are critical of the election in which
candidates must be screened by the
government and labeled as patriots in
order to run no one from hong kong's
largest opposition party participated in
the election results are expected to be
finalized monday
coming up why tornado ali may be carving
out a new road
more than a week after the state was hit
by five powerful tornadoes at least 77
people have died as a result of the
storms and hundreds more are homeless
officials say the damage could take
decades to repair
as the planet continues to warm there's
growing concern the u.s and canada could
see more powerful tornadoes in new
regions there's a shift in severe
weather patterns but they're not easy to
predict heather yorks west explains
it was an incredibly rare sight a
tornado touching down at the university
of british columbia the first tornado
spotted in metro vancouver in decades
and in november
only weeks later disaster when a cluster
of powerful tornadoes ripped through
several southern u.s states one tracking
a staggering 205 kilometers the
destruction was incalculable countless
homes and businesses gone dozens of
lives lost some of the missing remain
unaccounted for even experts are still
trying to understand it the longevity
the overnight in december it's it's
really in a class of its own the big
question then is this related to climate
change
that is the harder question while
climate scientists have good data to
predict what a changing climate will
mean for larger scale weather events
like floods and heat waves tornadoes are
more difficult to predict but there is
mounting evidence that the warming
climate will influence future tornadoes
too the models do tell us though that
a lot of the conditions the larger scale
conditions that are conducive to
tornadoes are will be on the increase
and that means new regions could see an
increase in tornado activity the
so-called tornado alley across the u.s
states of texas oklahoma kansas nebraska
and the dakotas appears to be shifting
eastward into the mississippi valley
that's where the december 10 tornadoes
cut a path of destruction through six
states some research suggests that
activity could eventually move north
into parts of canada as time goes on
here in manitoba the prairie climate
center had
is projecting that by
the middle of the century that southern
manitoba in the summertime we'll have a
climate similar to
to south dakota and nebraska exactly
what parts of the country could see more
tornadoes in the future scientists can't
yet say for sure the canadian building
codes have been changing to ensure
future builds will withstand heavier
winds keeping roofs on homes is key so
enhancing the connections
anchoring those roof connections is a
big big big part of it the cleanup
across the u.s will take some time but
as with so many efforts to clean up and
rebuild after the fires floods and
storms of 2021 there is that
ever-present thought there will be more
heather urex west global news calgary
still ahead the link to inc why it may
build trust in some professions
you're watching global national
tattoos are still considered taboo in
some circles but body art may not be the
perceived turn off it once was a new
canadian study shows getting inked may
give psychologists more credibility in
the eyes of potential clients montana
getty explains
for the longest time body art has been
deemed unprofessional or linked to
negative behavior however the stigma
around tattoos has been changing in
recent years a study done by a
university of saskatchewan researcher
shows psychologists are viewed as more
competent and trustworthy when they're
inked saskatoon tattoo artist and shop
owner haley gardner says it's about time
the entire stigma surrounding it is a
little bit ridiculous over 500
participants mainly in saskatchewan were
shown three different photos of the same
psychologist but one had a skull and
flower tattoo the tatted professional
was perceived to be more confident
empathetic and likable
having
super visible tattoos is a form of
vulnerability which i think people would
be able to relate to a lot researcher
alexandra zeidenberg found multiple
studies showing professionals in other
fields did not get the same response
people tended to perceive
tattooed medical professionals as being
less competent and they had more
negative feelings towards them according
to zeidenberg the shift in feelings
towards tattoos may be connected to a
younger audience or the profession
itself you're often spilling your
secrets and talking about really
personal information that might be a
little bit different from the way we
talk to other medical professionals
while gartner relates the change to
personal experience and human connection
tattoos often
are an indication of you know personal
struggle or triumph that this person has
decided to represent on their body
according to an ipsis read poll
conducted by global news back in 2011
two in 10 canadians have at least one
tattoo on their body although the number
has most likely jumped in the last
decade
montana getty global news saskatoon
hi there i'm donna friesen robin didn't
know this but i'm jumping in here to
deliver some news about our global
national family robin gill who is
anchoring tonight of course is leaving
us to pursue a new adventure this is her
last day on air and we know the
connection she's built with you our
viewers over the years and we didn't
want to let her leave without paying
tribute to her
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us she's always said she knew she'd be a
journalist french president emmanuel
macron and from the anchor desk the
extent of the storm damage here to the
field this is a fellow road and it's not
lost on the people who live here
robingill has excelled at delivering
news for more than 27 years the water
isn't going anywhere from the floods in
british columbia some of the stories rob
and just heartbreaking to the forest
fires in alberta right now this center
is a temporary home for them robin has
told countless stories of canadians
enduring and overcoming hardship dr
jesse griner has been treating and
studying patients always digging for a
deeper understanding what do you
attribute that to earning the respect of
her colleagues and exploring and
deciphering complex topics the picket
lines are back here at home but here in
the capitol the radiation levels and on
assignment overseas canadian todd hall
is hunkering down with his own stockpile
witnessing events in the field you have
this affinity for canada helping
canadians understand our world and their
ramping up efforts and the people in it
[Music]
from her days on the big breakfast
robin has been devoted to keeping
canadians informed newsweather wedding
we have it all here and she's never lost
her sense of humor i am chasing a plane
now she's moving on to a new adventure
that is global national for this sunday
night thanks robin
we all wish you the very best
[Music]
oh my goodness well as you just realized
this is my team thank you so much thank
you for some of that embarrassing stuff
too
um
after 21 years with global news tonight
is my final sign off and journalism has
been the love of my life and my
colleagues often joke it's been my
longest relationship so it was really
difficult to make this decision but i'm
leaving with this immense satisfaction
that i accomplished so much in my
27-year career and i'm grateful to
global for trusting me with so many
interesting assignments the best part
was that i could report across canada it
was always my goal and i'm proud to be a
canadian journalist my goal throughout
my career was to present the facts so
that you could make informed decisions
about the world we live in news is about
human connection stories that affect all
of us